[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في العراق
الشعبيه حيث شهدت البلاد وتظاهره قرب
البنك المركزي احتجاجا على تراجع سعر صرف
الدينار العراقي مقابل الدولار الف
العراقيين رفعوا شعارات تنتدب سياسه حكومه
محمد شويع السوداني الاقتصاديه وطالب رئيس
الحكومه قرارات تعيد الانتظار العراقي
سعره الطبيعي خصوصا وان هذا الانخفاض
المستمر في سعر التصريفه ادى الى
ارتفاعاتهم كبيره في اسعار الاغذيه
والسلعه والخدمات والتدهور القدره
الشرائيه للمواطنين وهو ما اثار طبعا
العديد من التساؤلات عن اسباب هذا
الانخفاض في سعر الصرف على الرغم من
ارتفاع الاحتياطيات النقديات لدى البنك
المركزي لما يصل الى 100 مليار دولار بحسب
وسائله اعلى من العراقيه دعت عديد من
الاحزاب والقوه السياسيه المعارضه الى
الاحتجاج امام مبنى المركزيه للتعبير عن
الرفد الشعبي لتراجع اسعار الصرف وفي
تقرير هاله عام 2022 كشفت هيئه النزاهه
الاتحاديه ان الخزينه العراقيه خسرت نحو
اربعه مليونات دينار جراء الفساد في بيع
العمله
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من بغداد
الدكتور عصام الفيل استاذ العلوم السياسيه
في جامعه المستنصريه ومن بغداد كذلك واثق
الجابري الباحث السياسي اهلا بكم ضيوف في
دكتور عصام اسمحلي ان ابدا بك هذه
الاحتجاجات يقولوا البعض بانها قادره ان
تتوسع ان تمتد هل قادره على الاطاحه
بحكومه السوداني او هناك مبالغه في قراءه
ذلك
نعم في البدايه تحيه لك يا سيدتي والى اخي
دكتور واثق ولكل من يتابعنا انا اعتقد
طبيعه هذه الاحتجاجات حينما قامت هي
بالاساس قامت على الطبقه السياسيه
وكلنا يعلم ان الازمه تتعدى السيد
السوداني وتتعدى السيد الكاظمي وتتعدى
السيد عادل عبد المهدي وحتى السيد العبادي
واكاد اذ ربما تتزوج حتى المالكي
الاشكاليه القائمه هو الخلل وفساد
المنظومه السياسيه منذ عام 2003 واليوم
الاخر
وبالتحديد يتوهم من يعتقد ان الازمه بدات
قبل عامين الازمه بدات قبل هذا في عام
2015 حينما نبه السيء الراحل السيد احمد
الشلبي الى طبيعه هذه الازمه وقال ان
هنالك ما يقارب اكثر من 500 مليار يتم
حقيقه تهريبها عبره مكاتب صيرفه او حتى
مصاريف وبالتالي هذه تساهم بصوره وباخرى
بهدر مال العراق مع امكانيه انديه يدخل
البنك الفيدرالي الامريكي لكن كما تعلمين
حينما ما تم اعداده من قبل السيد همم احمد
الشلبي كان بعشرات الملفات والوثائق وذهبت
نسخه منه الى البيدرال الامريكي الفيدرالي
الامريكي اجره تشيكن كامل على ما قام به
شلبي في هذا الموضوع وبالتالي اقول ان
القدره على معالجه هذه الازمه بحاجه الى
وقف سياسيه من قبل الجميع والا سيستهدف
النظام السياسي برمتي اذا لم يذهب العرب
والاكراد والسنه والشيعه وكل القوا
السياسيه في موضوعات المعالجه العلميه
وادخل اسس الفنيه القائمه على اساس ما
يعرب من اتمته او اقول الليغاذر في
الواقعه تتحدث عن تهريب العمله وهذا
الموضوع كنا ناقشناها في حلقاتنا السابقه
وكان حتى معنى الاستاذ جابري كنت معنا
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع وكنت حظرتك يعني
استبعت هذه الفرضيه قلت بانه الازمه
الحاليه ليست ازمه تهريب بقدر ما هي همم
ازمه همم عمله اجنبيه ولكن ضيفي من جديد
يضع همم موضوع التهريب ويعتبر بان الحكومه
الحاليه صحيح بانها لا تتحمل مسؤوليتان
كامله هناك حكومات اخرى قبل هوا ولكن هي
كذلك لم تجد حلولا لذلك ما رايك
مشاهديكم الكرام دكتور عصام نعم همم
بالحقيقه يعني اولا هو هذه الازمه الماليه
هي جزء من الانعكاسات الفوضويه لطبيعه
السياسه واداره الاموال وبالتالي للعراق
وليس بلد الفقيرا يوميا بحدود 300 الى 400
ااه مليون دولار مبيعات النفط اضافه الى
ذلك يعني هي المشكله الان بدات الازمه منذ
واحد 11 يعني قمه هذه الازمه يعني بدات
تصاعد مبيعات البنك المركزي ارتفعت من 25
مليون دولار يوميا الى
292 مليون دولار وبالتالي هنالك ايادي
خفيه كانت
تهرب العمله وهي هنا القضيه بطبيعه
التعاملات الحكومه السابقه كانت تعمل
بمعزل عن همم اداره او سياسه الملك الملك
الثاني
الحكومه الحاليه مواد الحديث عن الحكومه
الحاليه وعن هذه الاحتجاجات وكيف سيتم هل
تهدئه تصعيد كيف سيكون موضوع
اتخذت جمله من الخطوات وجدت سياسه البنك
المركزي خاطئه وبالتالي استبدلت يعني
محافظ البنك المركزي هنالك عده خطط هي في
دعم الاتمته والتحول الالكتروني
والدعم المنتج الوطني
ودعم الانتاج على همم
والتحويلات تكون الحساب الانتاج وليس همم
على همم حساب الاستهلاك وبالتالي محاوله
متابعه الاموال المحوله وطبيعه حركه
الاموال والمتابعه تكون الكترونيه حتى بعض
التجاره الذين تتعامل معهم الحكومه الان
بدات تطلب منه بان يكون التعامل
الالكتروني لكي يتم همم معرفه من هي جهات
التي تقوم بطبيعه التاريخ
تحديث هذه الجهات وهي خاصه يعني انا اقول
التشخيص اولا يعني من هي الجهات هو كانت
الاموال تحول يعني او تذكر الاموال التي
كنا تحول الى الخارجيه كانت
حدود 40% الى البنوك التي تم معاقبتها
وكانت هي للاسف هي كانت حتى بعلم البنك
الفدرالي الامريكي لكن اليوم هو البنك
الفدرالي بدا بمعاقبه هذه البنوك وبالتالي
همم خلق نوع من المخاوف لدى البنوك الاخرى
لذلك الحكومه اليوم تريد ان تعطي تطوينات
وتتعامل مع شركات ومعانيه
همم
نقاط محاوله ايجاد الحال ما رايك همم
هل فعلا بان الحكومه الحاليه كما يستبعد
كثير في الواقعه دكتور
بدات تشخص وتفهم وهي بصدد ايجاد حلول
يعني بعض الاجراءات ذهبت الحكومه اليها
بما يتوافق مع الهجران الامريكي خفضت
طبيعه المبيعات في النسبه البنك المركزي
العراقي من 250 مليون دولار يوميا الى 57
مليون دولار بمعنى هذه الحكومه سائره في
هذا الاطار ذهبوا الى موضوعات معالجه اقول
ما يعرف بالسله الغذائيه وبعض الاجراءات
لكن تبقى هنالك اشكاليه اليوم نتحدث نحن
عن كثير من شركات الصيرفه التي لا تقدم
الاوراق وبالتالي حتى مبيعات العمله حينما
خفظت هؤلاء نزلوا الى السوق وحقيقه
يمتلكوه كثير من الاموال العراقيه وما
سامع في ارتفاع موضوع الدولار وبالتالي
الحكومه ذهبت الى اجراء يعني اقول اغلقت
كثير وتابعت كثير من الجهات التي تحاول
صحيحه
يلقى نتائج عن بعض المتوسط الى همم على
المدى المتوسط الى البعيد هذه الاحتجاجات
تريد حلول ااا انيه هل هذا تقدر عليه
الحكومه
يعني هذا يتوقف على سفر السيد محمد الشيعه
السوداني في الزياره القادمه وتفاهمه مع
الحكومه الامريكيه وهذا يرتبط بملفات
الحكومه الامريكيه لديها ملف حقيقه طبيعه
العلاقه الامريكيه العراقيه وماهيه اليه
هذه العلاقه العراق اريد موضوع الدولار
وبالتالي اقول هذا بالاساس تحكموا طبيعه
التفاهمات السياسيه المشكله القائمه ان كل
الاحزاب تتحمل المسؤوليه لان هي تمتلك
مكاتب الصايره والبنوك وهي التي تتاجر
بقوه المواطن العراقي اليوم بل ان هذا
ذهبت الى ابعد من ذلك في محاوله للضغط على
السيد محمد اشياء السوداني بطريقه او
باخرى ظنا منها انه سيستجيب لهم لذلك
تفاقه مثل الازمه حتى داخل القطار
التنسيقي ومع الاحزاب الكرديه ومع الاحزاب
الاخرى شكرا شكرا لك من بغداد الدكتور
عصام الفليلي استاذه العلوم السياسيه
جامعه المستنصريه ومن بغداد كذلك وثق
الجابري الباحث السياسي شكرا جزيلا على
المشاركه والحضور